Traduttore: Isabella Ricci
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
C'è un libro, della giornalista
e scrittrice Caitlin Moran,
che è uscito qualche anno fa,
che in originale si intitola
"How to be a Woman":
come essere una donna.
Lo diceva già Simone de Beauvoir
negli anni quaranta:
Donne non si nasce.
Donne si diventa.
"Donne" non è una
condizione pre-esistente,
non è qualcosa che sei e basta.
Donna è un processo,
con degli step quasi tutti obbligatori.
Donna, prima ancora
che una "cosa", è un "come".
Fra le tante cose difficili
che si possono fare se si è una donna,
quello che sto facendo io,
in questo momento,
è una delle più difficili in assoluto:
parlare per 10, 12 minuti
senza essere interotta -
preferibilmente da un uomo
è una specie di evento eccezionale.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
E quando lo fai notare,
c'è quasi sempre un uomo che ti interrompe
per dirti che non è vero.
Io sono nata nel 1972.
All'epoca, una gravidanza
era un po' uno shock/sorpresa:
che io sarei stata femmina,
i miei l'hanno scoperto
nel momento preciso della mia nascita,
non un minuto prima.
Non hanno avuto quattro, cinque mesi
per proiettarmi addosso le loro fantasie
di come sarei stata.
Sono nata, ero piccoletta,
secca, calva - e femmina!
Sono una femmina cis-gender.
Ovvero, se pensiamo al genere
come una collina da scavallare -
non è proprio così, ma facciamo come se -
io mio trovo già ai piedi
del lato che mi corrisponde.
Sono di qua, sono "cis".
Comunque, nasci e sei,
chi più chi meno, femmina.
E passi buona parte della tua vita
a imparare a diventare una donna.
È un processo di addizione e sottrazione.
Per lo più di sottrazione,
perché per essere una Donna,
con la D maiuscola
come cantava Carmen Consoli,
bisogna imparare a togliere, essere meno:
meno rumorose, meno disordinate,
meno esuberanti, meno disinvolte.
Se poi una aspira
alla qualifica di "Signora",
la sottrazione si fa estrema.
La signora, la vera signora, è elegante;
e l'eleganza è minimalismo,
asciuttezza, rinuncia.
Essere donna significa,
anche e soprattutto,
imparare a occupare meno spazio nel mondo.
La magrezza non è associata alla bellezza
per questioni di salute,
come si raccontano i grasso-fobici.
Lasciate perdere.
A parte che della salute altrui
alla gente non frega assolutamente nulla.
Il problema è la percezione
del corpo femminile
come qualcosa che ha, sopratutto,
la funzione di essere guardata.
E quando quello sguardo
non trova appagamento,
allora quel corpo deve essere nascosto.
Siamo passati da "Non permetterai
che una strega viva",
che è tutto sommato
aveva una sua maestosità,
con grandissima scioltezza a:
"Non permetterai che una donna grassa
si metta un scamiciato".
Più magre, più belle, e più curate:
sono le unici "più"
che ci siano veramente concessi.
La cosa che ti viene martellata
nel cervello, quando sei una ragazza,
è che a nessuno importa cosa pensi.
Il pensiero delle ragazze
è sempre trascurabile, e irrelevante.
A nessuno importa davvero
cosa pensano, vogliono
e desiderano le ragazze.
Anzi, quando le ragazze
prendono una parola, vengono aggredite.
Pensate a Greta, pensate a Malala.
E ricordatevi che Malala
è una che è sopravvissuta
a uno che le ha sparato in testa.
Oh, intendiamoci: per le ragazze
ci si preoccupa tantissimo!
Ci si preoccupa di cosa indossano,
di come parlano, di cosa mangiano,
di chi frequentano.
Ci si preoccupa di dire loro
che devono stare attente.
Che non devono uscire la notte da sole,
che devono scegliere con cura
le persone da frequentare.
Intorno alle ragazze
si costruisce un muro solidissimo
di piccole e grandi limitazioni
della libertà personale,
perchè "là fuori è un brutto mondo".
L'unica cosa di cui non ci si preoccupa
è fare il modo che i ragazzi
non siano il brutto mondo delle ragazze.
(Applauso)
Da dietro questo muro, in qualche modo,
dovremmo imparare a essere leader.
E se non ci riusciamo,
se lasciamo la leadership ai maschi,
ci viene detto che è colpa nostra,
che non ci proponiamo,
che non siamo coraggiose
che non vogliamo emergere,
che preferiamo restare nell'ombra.
È qui che entra il femminismo.
In realtà, entra anche
in altri lati dell'esistenza
perché non c'è lato, davvero,
in cui il femminismo non possa entrare
e riscrivere, ribaltare
e riscostruire tutto.
Il femminismo, per chi si fosse perso
le puntate precedenti,
nasce più o meno alla fine del '700
con il pamphlet di Mary Wollstonecraft,
che si intitolava "A Vindication
of the Rights of Woman"
All'epoca le donne non erano niente:
non possedevano niente,
non potevano studiare,
non potevano lavorare fuori casa,
non potevano votare.
Wollstonecraft è
fra le prime a rivendicare
il diritto delle donne di essere umane,
di esistere anche fuori
dalle mure domestiche.
Da allora,
la teoria femminista si è evoluta,
ha prodotto opere raffinatissime.
Ha cambiato obiettivo!
Difende ancora i diritti,
anche se i diritti
che difende sono cambiati,
ma non si incarica più, soltanto,
di tutelare il nostro diritto a esistere
in un mondo di cui
non scriviamo le regole,
ma si occupa anche
di riscrivere le regole,
di renderle più eque
e liberatorie per tutti.
Il femminismo non crea un mondo anarchico:
crea un mondo in cui
la spartizione del potere
sia sostituita della condivisione
della conoscenza e delle risorse.
Collaborazione, li dove adesso
c'è competizione;
solidarietà, al posto della sopraffazione.
Chi non lo vorebbe?
Eh, un sacco di gente, a quanto pare.
(Ride)
Essere leader, essere donna,
mettersi alla testa di qualcosa,
di un partito, di un movimento,
di un team professionale,
è una facenda complessa.
Ed è ancora più complessa
perché, dovunque si giri,
vede solo il muro
che le hanno costruito intorno.
Non si può essere leader
da dietro un muro.
Leader non si nasce, leader si diventa.
La leadership è fatta di responsabilità,
capacita di rischiare
e di assumersi il peso del rischio,
polso, coraggio e tenuta.
La leader femminista
non si defenisce come tale
per la sua capacità di emergere,
ma per la capacità di collaborare,
e creare a sua volta nuove leader.
Il femminismo non è
occupazione degli spazi,
è moltiplicazione degli spazi,
delle voci, dei punti di vista.
Man mano che si sale
sulla scala del prestigio,
lo dicono le statistiche,
i maschi sono sempre di più.
Tutte le caratteristiche che ho elencato
come tratti distintivi della buona leader
vengono spazzati via
davanti alla leadership
così come la conosciamo,
che è competitiva,
verticistica: mai un dubbio!
Un uomo solo al commando,
come Achab sulla tolda del Pequod.
Ci ricordiamo tutti
che fine ha fatto Achab
con tutto il Pequod, vero?
La leadership come la conosciamo
è una leadership fragile.
È basata sul culto della personalità,
non sulla creazione
e condivisione di idee.
È una leadership
che gli uomini si trasmettono,
si tramandano e si contendono
in circoli esclusivi,
in cui le uniche donne ammesse
sono quelle capaci
di replicare, esattamente,
le stesse dinamiche di sopraffazione
e di conquista dell'avversario.
(Applausi)
Succede in tutti gli ambienti lavorativi.
Più si sale, più soldi ci sono
più è difficile per una donna farsi spazio
in una società che predilige
l'aggressività e la sicurezza di sé,
anche quando non è sostenuta
da capacità adeguate.
Certo, anche le femmine
sanno essere tremende:
anzi, la formula giusta è
"Le donne sono le peggiori nemiche
le une delle altre",
perché prima ti insegnano
che nella vita fanno strada solo quelli
che la affrontano con cattiveria;
poi ti puniscono, perché
"una donna non si comporta così!".
Una donna con la D maiuscola è gentile,
comprensiva, premurosa, accogliente.
Quello che in un uomo
è normale temperamento, è carattere,
in una donna è...
essere stronza!
(Applausi)
Anzi -
Stronza con la S maiuscola!
(Applausi)
Essere donna, e essere leader,
presupone sul superamento
di un grandissimo timore
che è quello di parlare in campo aperto
invece di bisbigliare
nell'orecchio dell'uomo di turno.
Avete presente, no?
"La grande donna dietro il grande uomo"
A questo proposito,
vorrei raccontare un aneddoto.
Sono almeno un paio d'anni
che mi trovo a parlare
di femminismo e questioni di genere
in situazioni pubbliche,
a volte anche molto pubbliche,
È successo dopo che, con il mio gruppo
di discussione femminista,
abbiamo lanciato la campagna
#quellavoltache,
che si è occupata di aprire il discorso
sulle molestie sessuali in Italia,
partendo dalla rete.
Io mi sono incaricata
di andare a parlarne,
quindi sui giornali, in radio,
in televisione,
ovunque ce ne fosse necessità.
È un lavoro impegnativo,
perché bisogna tenere l'occhio sulla palla
e non farsi distrarre,
perché quando sei femminista in pubblico
la gente pretende che tu salti
come una foca ammaestrata
quando le tirano le sardine,
al grido di: "Dove sone le femministe?"
Perché delle donne abbiamo
un idea subalterna;
o dicono quello che vuoi tu,
oppure non sono degni
delle qualifiche che si sono meritate.
Per fare tutto questo,
ho dovuto superare alcune grandi paure.
La prima era la paura
di dire stupidaggini in pubblico;
La seconda era la paura
di presentarmi come femminista
senza essere stata accreditata
da altre femministe.
La terza era che la gente
potesse pensare che avevo ragione,
e quindi decidesse di darmi credito.
Il che mi avrebbe posto nella posizione
di essere un riferimento per gli altri,
che è una posizione
di grande responsabilità.
Insomma, ho fatto
un incontro con le scuole,
parlavo di femminismo, come al solito.
Alla fine dell'incontro,
mi si avvicina uno degli insegnanti
e mi dice, "Hai uno stile
di conduzione molto maschile!"
(Risate)
Io non so che faccia ho fatto,
perché non so mai che faccia faccio
quando prendono a riferimento
lo stile dei maschi
per farmi un complimento;
e siccome sono una donna,
sono stata educata a essere gentile,
non me lo volevo mangiare
e risputare lì sul momento.
E avevo capito, anche,
che lui voleva essere gentile con me.
Insomma, la morale della favola è questa:
passi tutta la tua vita,
o buona parte della tua vita,
a imparare a essere una donna;
ma all'atto pratico, quello che conta,
quando vai là fuori nel mondo,
è somigliare il più possibile a un uomo.
(Applausi)
Ho 46 anni, e ne ho impiegati almeno 30
a cercare di diventare una donna
essendo io a dettare le condizioni.
Ma una cosa ho imparato a farla:
non ho più paura della mia voce!
(Applausi)
Grazie!